almost a week on and still more
questions than answers Sana Khan and
Joseph abbess were the victims of a
Seaside tragedy with fatal consequences
son is mum Stephanie Williams tweeted on
Wednesday I lost my beautiful daughter
at Bournemouth Beach Sana was so well
loved and well liked no parent should
ever have to go through what her dad and
I are going through we love you so much
baby girl
the families are hoping the inquest
which opened today bullshed some clarity
on what went so wrong here at
Bournemouth Coroner's Court we heard
that Sana Khan and Joe abetti's
provisional cause of death was drowning
at the inquest has been adjourned until
the 18th of September while the
coroner's office await the results from
a police investigation
but five days on and still family say
they know very little apart from what's
already in the public domain
that this boat was impounded by the
police and a man in his 40s was charged
with suspected manslaughter last week
but was released on Thursday pending
investigation
a police failing according to local MP
Tobias Elwood
we live in an age of social media and
it's been unhelpful with so much wild
speculation as to what might have caused
this I think there are some lessons to
be learned perhaps of summarizing the
instance so we can have peace of mind
for those parents for example that want
to make sure it's safe for their
children to go onto the beach
Dorset police however say the matter is
complex as it involves multiple agencies
and so they're keeping an open mind with
their inquiries calling on eyewitnesses
to come forwards
in the meantime for the families all
they could do is wait as they come to
terms with their loss Saba choudhary Sky
News Bournemouth